Joe Buck legend Joe bark what's going on
how are we welcome to the show thank you
how you doing I'm good are we on we are
on yes love it I love walking in just go
yeah call you you're bigger than I
thought you'd be I am a little over 6 1
oh ok that's a good height
well that's cuz I work with a giant yep
who's your boy Troy Aikman oh I like
Troy I crush I know that yeah 6 5 but by
the way yesterday Jim was talking about
what a cowboy's fanny is we about going
hey who do you work over here sorry I
didn't buy my car Roger Staubach's
dealership either here right big you'd
think if Troy Aikman was still on
television you see so many these guys to
get out just forget who's teamed up like
oh yeah yeah it's fine but when I said
giant a3 off but he's bigger than you
think and I guess people meet me and
they think I'm gonna be like 5 - what is
he like 6 6 Troy I should play like 6 5
I don't know but he's got you know he's
just he's a large human yeah yeah yeah
your girls must love him you think so
yeah chicks love him yeah right yeah I
walk around with a man Ivan know I'm
there that's humiliating right it's a
civilian yeah freeing for some weird
reason because I can do whatever I want
I can walk around nobody's looking right
but Joe doesn't need to underplay
himself I was reading that article that
the ringer did about you yeah and they
talked about how you met your wife and
then she was a reporter total stalk job
right and that you were just like hey
tell tell the reporter down there that
Joe Buck wants to talk to her yeah and
she got the message no he set it down
and said to tell him someone wants to
talk to me I hope it's not Joe Baca
that's like she said literally and the
guy the go-between so why would you say
that she goes you know I don't know I've
never heard anything bad about him he
just looks like a smug arrogant jerk
yeah yeah why don't you think that about
you that became a metaphor for your
career yeah I mean that's kind of what I
deal with yeah that's why I wrote a
friggin book right like here I'm not the
smug arrogant jerk that you think I am
it's why I called a lucky bastard I am I
am a lucky bastard but why do people
think that I I think because of my style
on TV and I do baseball and every
baseball fan wants to hear their home
guys and I'm the national guy and so
they get pissed no matter what you say
and then I guess my style comes off like
I I think bigger or better than the game
it's actually the other way around I try
to talk get out of the way and let the
game go I never got the impression like
the only pronounced as a Yankee fan
I always thought Joe Morgan didn't like
the Yankees and then some was like yeah
cuz the Big Red Machine is like that the
late 90s Aggies are being compared to
that but that's the only time I ever
felt that I never got the impression
that you were Pro in New York or like I
go what are you eight the Yankees I did
a thing for Funny or Die on that where
people are MF and me everywhere I go and
that's just kind of that's they're not
unique
Kansas City thinks the same thing in San
Francisco because you're used to hearing
guys openly rooting on air for your team
my manager Jonathan Sam and I were in LA
for the World Series and I managed a big
Cubs fan and whenever you would talk
you'd be like he hates the Cubs act
especially when the Cubs were down by
the way when it comes we're down he'd be
like Oh Joe [ __ ] buckets he's talking
about the case of listen he's not
talking about the Cubs enthusiastic
right he's so by in any way his wife
would just try to be nice I go yeah he's
bias yeah well I think maybe I could be
wrong the bias is in the ear of the
listener more than it is I mean come on
if you just take it on face value as an
announcer I'm the only one to ever call
them winning the World Series in the
history of television there's there's a
little bit uh you know I could be
accused of going the other way on that
so he's wrong telling me to is your
manager he's my my comedy manager yeah
he sucks it's so interesting that I feel
like you know reading the book and
reading about you like the the
criticisms and the stuff people say
about you like they have a pretty deep
affect on you like it seems like it hits
you uh yeah I think it's death by a
thousand cuts you know once you get it
enough you know but but here's the thing
in person people are great even in New
York do you hate the Yankees no I don't
okay what shot you drinking then they'll
buy a shot and you know I think you kind
of get looked at as a as a thing and
it's like kill the messenger like
you just said when the Cubs aren't
playing well they're down 3 2 1 I sound
like I hate the Cubs because I'm
screaming and yelling for the Indians
but but then they get mad because I turn
around and start screaming for the Cubs
when they come back in the series so
yeah I think I'm too thin-skinned and
I'm trying to get better at that I go to
therapy for that you do hell yeah it's a
Finn Diego not enough what I want now
like once every three weeks four weeks
does really help you and I not to this
point no well make it go more really
sure yeah I walk out of there I feel a
little lighter I feel a little more
myself feel like the old Joe the
fighting Joe right and then you know a
couple tweets later and not happy it is
weird how like the negative stuff on
social
there's a million positive things but
the one negative thing they're
validating what I already knew shitty
exactly it's so it's so it's like the
highs and the lows too cause it's so
easy especially in the business you're
in I'm sure for somebody to like really
lift you up like you like the right
person says that you did a great job on
this call like you're through the
through the roof but then all you need
is that one person right to say the
wrong thing and it's a total stranger
and your days ruins it makes no sense
yeah I mean if you think about it yeah
but I don't and I'm not that smart so I
just kind of let it hit you are changed
I was interested your Cardinals fan too
it changed the way you called them
winning like you said that you think you
got yeah I I can't you have that quality
I honestly don't remember it but I'm
sure you didn't suck in 2010 it makes me
cringe it's the only was that that that
was when they played the Mets they why
would they plan now that was in the NLCS
yeah then and here's what happened the
background is I'm at Shea right they put
my face on the scoreboard a I'm always
going to be associated with the
Cardinals and fans booed because it's
the same stuff you know he hates my team
he's yelling for the other team well
then I get to the World Series they're
playing the Tigers and I'm hearing
adherent adhering it they end up winning
and I'm like that's a literally Colonel
of the first world so it sucked cuz they
got in your head it got my because the
booing and everything and when they were
booing you was it just because of your
face or
well I I'm enthusiastic a huge head
that's what it was I think they were
booing the sack that's what I told my
Sony they're not booing me they're
booing the sight of my boxers the first
thing you said in therapy I can't find a
[ __ ] hat yeah yeah if I could if I
could somehow come up with you know a
hat that fit this head I'm like seven
and seven eighths yeah big having those
that's not like a gift shop hat no I
mean you have to special order that's my
hat size too really yeah and it's really
I never wear hats ever ever cause it
looks stupid
yeah it looks ridiculous yeah like I'm
something a bucket I have a weird size
head but my face doesn't look good in
hats can I have no chin drive around
[ __ ] dopey moon face and it just
doesn't I knew I knew I had a really bad
face for hat years ago I'll girlfriend
letters days just like you look terrible
in hats you look like the little you
look like a little kid but you're
looking a little kid in the sandlot when
you wear hats like the brim looks way
too tall right yeah really awful um when
you bit so when you make that call like
you instantly know that was terrible or
one of those you listen I mean you're in
the moment you're hearing the crowd
coming through your headset think okay I
nailed that one and then I hear it years
later like you let me ask you a question
John sterling but for the Yankees yes I
love John sterling and I hate him like I
think that he's one of the best like
when he's genuinely just doing the
regular play-by-play stuff or calling a
home run I love him but then he puts
these little names on people and I'm
like I understand why announcers get
caught up you hate when he said because
it sounds like he's going into business
for himself when he makes it about
himself it's almost like when he's just
doing the regular you know two and two
strike three like I love him I just
voice is awesome I think he's great I he
gets picked on in the post with Phil
Mushnik like every show Mushnik ever
seen anything nice about anybody [ __ ]
that guy's the worse it gets
you know I get thrown in there all the
time it's like you not like you - yeah
you didn't he you know what he said
about me earlier my career Joe Buck
tries to be funny too much that's like
the worst thing it's not he gets too
silly sometimes he's trying to be funny
right that's the worst but I don't
really consider him the arbiter of he's
the war he's literally the worst I've
never read in so much I don't read him I
mean I've never her
like there's no balance there's very
little bow no yeah that's this whole
thing that's a stick like I'm the
curmudgeon oh look out for Phil but it's
might always funny that when you it's
like you know how dare they do this and
you know the Fox went into the gutter
with this and then if you pick up the
post right below his column is like ads
for strip joints it's I'm so right with
the covers of the post they show they
show mass shooters knowing that that
encourages more mass shooters they're
really in no moral position to complain
about anything yeah we can do seminars
on this yeah you're sure we probably
want a living hell oh no people get it
so are you I you a you an insecure guy
I'm an insecure guy totally you are yeah
who's not I mean if you're not an
insecure guy you're a dick I don't know
man some people I admire who have a
certain like a decent amount of
confidence without being cocky there's
people who have the appropriate amount
of confident I grew up as a fat kid I'm
a bald guy by nature I I was picked on
as a as a kid and in the school
playground so for me that for being fat
so you have that like because if we talk
about it with with girls a lot when like
you there's an attractive girl who has
no self-confidence is because she used
to be fat and she still has fat girl
mentality absolutely and doesn't realize
she could just get whatever she wants I
interviewed Michael Phelps on this other
show I do on DirecTV and I put the we
put the cover up of him with all the
gold medals around his neck for Sports
Illustrated I said what do you see when
you see this picture he said I see an
awkward guy with big ears said the rest
of the world sees 18 gold medals around
your neck and you see a person with big
ears and awkward looking any so that's
what I got made fun of that's all I see
when I see that picture
it is weird have the old like those old
tapes yeah from from from being a kid
they just they're louder than anything
you achieve as an adult it's being that
[ __ ] loser or that frightened idiot
yeah that plays much louder than I had
all my friends were dating girls and I
had a buddy Kevin O'Malley and I would
sit in his basement watch a vacation for
the 58th time on a Friday night
everybody else was like trying to get
beer
you know before being 21 and datin
checks and wait-wait-wait Joe did you
just say as a child you watched
something other than baseball this is
not going to be good for you I know this
is not you should down that they should
not you mean you watch vacation
Fletch yeah Chevy Chase's entire cat
much yeah so yeah I was not living and
dying and breathing sports constantly
and nor do I now I I have a life I I
have friends I do other stuff that's
what homina what made you have the
strength to ask your wife repeatedly
then because that's something I'm like
one gun guy how do you if you're
insecure there was something about her
that she had a boyfriend she live with a
guy yeah and and I just I just kept
going and I don't know why and it was so
unlike me and the fact that I I found
this as a personal challenge and and I
literally was going to be a restraining
order or marriage did you actually would
you did you put like he's keep calling
her or would you kind of bump into her
and go hey I'm trying to get to her
through an intermediary Rich Eisen of
the NFL Network and eventually is like
you know what you're both good people
here's her number here's his number you
two work it out and then we did and I
wore her down and now she's my wife of
two and a half years see I never know
like that's the encouraging part of
asking somebody more than once because I
usually ask once that like [ __ ] but
like sometimes I guess you just know I
just knew and believe me I'd gone
through divorce I have older kids I was
the last guy that was gonna get
remarried and and I got married and I'm
thankful that I did and you talk about a
lot of stuff that guys wouldn't talk
like I lose my leg about like you talked
about the hair plugs you talked about
being bald like you you seem to like
like talking about things other it's
they're afraid of I don't know yeah why
it was one of the promo stories for the
book though like it way like you were
like hey I got a book coming out guess
what I had nine hair replacement
surgeries I was addicted to them that's
my voice well here's the thing and what
I found out is anytime and it was said
tongue-in-cheek I mean that's a lot of
the book is that way but when I said
addicted you'd be in say it's the worst
most painful procedure you could ever do
it's torture so that was a joke I wasn't
it addicted to hair plug surgery
I'm freebasing hair plugs in my corner
you you you I guess you're addicted to
the results but I'm very happy to never
do it again it sucks yeah but yeah so I
don't care
about talking about that stuff and that
the only problem was that I felt like
and I said on the air that like after
that story came out because we all got
such a kick out of it we were talking
about it but then every time they would
show like close-ups of your face at the
world you read about is my hair 100%
yeah just looking out yourself about
stuff like that because like if I say it
they can't get me because I kind of do
that like if you say it they can't
attack you with it because never owning
it I don't know yeah I mean I've people
will say they'll make fun of the size of
my forehead
on Twitter well I don't get I don't get
that too much yeah it's like when I'm
sure they're perfect out there and all
this stuff but I'm like you think you
know you think this is bad now had I not
gone through eight rounds of torture
really ugliest [ __ ] I've ever seen on
television in high definition
Darrin eh yeah you like what you see
when you watch yourself back ready like
oh yeah I'm in the middle I'm not always
uh but if you know right outfit right
right coloring good makeup a nice hair
job I'm passable
I don't feel alright yeah you're not the
type of the goes in and goes no no
makeup this is I want to go natural when
does that your boy Eggman does he does
no makeup he hates it and so then he
shows up and he's you know oily and
glistening and they're like please put
makeup on and you just can't stand it I
I don't like it either
no what does he say no [ __ ] 52 to 17
makeup on [ __ ] right yeah by the way
Joe's book you be lucky bastard it is
out
is it a Tuesday's the day DNA and Joe's
also tomorrow I can be in conversation a
great place with Michael K at the 92y
92y dot org for tickets he also has book
signings which are on the last page of
his bio so I guess we have to find out
where they are on November on Thursday
at the Yogi Berra museum 92nd Street Y
by the way sarsen yeah in Little Falls
New Jersey sold out on November 21st and
st. Louis on November 23rd you're gonna
be in Grapevine Texas with Troy Aikman
yeah I'm just calling in people that I
think la crowd and oh by the way Jose
here with his book I've got John Hamm in
st. Louis I've got a common
in Dallas and I figure hey you know
they're gonna come to see those people
and maybe they'll buy a book well that's
great that's a great idea that's the
thing that I found like so interesting
about you is that and I guess it's it's
the right way to live is that publicly
like in terms of like the masses you
have the insecurities that you deal with
right where they're criticizing you and
everything but in your life where you
have friends that are one-on-one like
the friends that you have are the people
that literally everybody would want to
be friends with Jon Hamm and Paul Rudd
and Eddie Vedder and like these guys are
your friends so you're sitting there and
people admire all those guys but they're
not sitting there going well if those
guys think he's cool then he must be
cool right right but I'm not gonna go
you know maybe that's why I wrote the
book did you let everybody know when
your famous friends are friends are ya
yeah and you know Kate Hudson likes me
why don't you yeah Eddie Vetter likes me
why don't you know did he accuse you
being a biased and then my managers a
Cubs fan Eddie's a Cubs fans you know
why you of it cuz Eddie Vedder's not a
dick that's a good thing Jonathan
Brandt's teens today yeah I think and
for the rest of time yeah ever I'm doing
a Cubs game uh-huh mekka Jonathan's
little smug ass face every time I'm
doing a call give it a little extra yeah
yeah make fun of the ivy that shitty
weed doesn't wife and his placating wife
who's going you're right honey he
doesn't like the cup was she right and
in fairness though she was trying to
keep him from throwing us off the
balcony she was just trying to prevent a
suicide so she she was doing her duty
that's fair I get it but is really when
you're watching a thing you put so much
into your team I didn't get with Brett
Butler in 97 and I saw her recently I
hadn't seen her since and she goes are
you still a big Yankees fan I had
forgotten that I would that was a
Cleveland Indians they had lost in the I
think the ALCS were the division series
for the Indians and I was going so
[ __ ] crazy at Caroline's and I was so
miserable that she remembered that
almost 20 years later that I couldn't
handle the Yankees losing in a serious
sport says a really powerful place in
people's lives and so when you were
there and you're the voice calling one
team's winning they're all good they
don't care the team that loses
wants to kill the person screaming and
yelling for the other team that's just
the life I think there's also a thing
where like most people who watch sports
aren't looking on the field and thinking
I could be that guy you know I mean like
no like they don't think I could be a
professional athlete maybe a couple of
people who were good in high school but
I think a lot of people watch thinking
that they could have your job no doubt
and I am I would love to gather them all
up and have them sit down one by one
I'll go I here's my Twitter go yeah and
it's just you don't just walk in and do
the game that said you know I think a
lot of them probably could eventually
figure it out it's not like disarming a
nuclear weapon it's hard it's not that
easy to do because you don't know what
when do you talk when do you not talk
it's not an easy thing to do like
especially if it's football I think is
harder because it's constant movement so
it's like with baseball you have a
second but it's still not easy to know
but that's the part that freaks some
people out if you see action at least
you can write you can call action but
now okay nothing's happening what are
you going to say and and that's why when
young people send me their tapes you're
like hey I want to get into broadcasting
here's my highlight reel if I'm hiring I
don't care how you call the homerun I
want to know what you're doing on foul
balls and on ball three and talking
about the giveaway night and all that
that to me is where you earn your money
not on the highlights ever anybody can
scream and yell what's the worst sports
lost you've ever taken sport like just
want like no OD gambler no no I I don't
but I don't think of my father's son but
uh see the gambler yeah yeah yeah that
kept him alive I think the last five
years of his life and not to win a bunch
of money I think he just liked figuring
out who he thought was going to win but
did it did you ever lose a lot of money
cuz gamblers are hard to live with yeah
he was like a craps guy was a
depression-era kid never had money was
dirt poor and then once he had a little
bit of money we would go to LA I was ten
and you know he would we'd go to Vegas
on the way home he died play Donkey Kong
all night and he'd roll craps and we'd
meet me in the room at 7:00 a.m. and
back to st. Louis we'd go so what kind
of wood you knew when he had a good
night or a bad oh yeah and with
overnight we left like let's just go
this yeah there's no he was pissed yeah
I mean I remember one time he wide a
hundreds and I've never seen him happier
and then another times like well we
worked for free this week buck don't
tell your mother and then back home we
want was ever in danger of like losing
the home right now oh oh yeah he didn't
have a problem okay no he just like pink
you just like to gamble what was it
about his lifestyle that made you follow
like what may just be like happy I mean
even by the end of his life he had
Parkinson's and diabetes and he had a
pacemaker but he was shaking and but he
could not wait to get down to the
ballpark to do a game and when you see
that as a kid man sign me up oh yeah I
saw other people's parents were not that
happy was he insecure no but he didn't
deal with all this stuff
he wasn't World War two and he was
injured in Germany and he was a Purple
Heart recipient I think once you go
through all that it's like pocket I
what's the worst that can happen what do
you find yourself struggling with more
when you're calling a game like are you
saying they're trying to prove to people
that you're a good commentator or trying
to god other than the you know we don't
have to play the clip but other than
that call even even with the heightened
craziness of Cubs Indians once the game
starts that I don't think about any of
that you just think I don't do the game
and none of that stuff bothers me but
it's the downtime in between games I'm
like you know yeah screw you right kind
of right you guys throwing stats at you
constantly cause it's like I hate stats
you do and if I'm relying on stats as
opposed to my eyes or being observant of
what's actually happening or who's in
the bullpen who's left what could happen
if I'm just reading numbers I that's
that's boring to me are you doing a
twenty years so how has it changed
because we taught political correctness
and the way TV is so uptight a lot of
guys it's so hard to not so many guys in
the sports world because sports guys
talk a certain way get in trouble for
like a comment that will be okay in the
locker room that's not even it's unreal
and it's and I saw it from my dad you
know
I talk about that a little bit in the
book you know my dad made jokes or made
light of situations that if you did now
if you did that now you wouldn't last
till the end of the inning
you they'd come in and like send you to
Guantanamo Bay after saying some of the
stuff that he got away with and it was
just kind of laughed off now does that
make it right I'm not saying it's right
but the business has changed to the
point where when you're doing a game for
40 million people in Game seven of a
World Series and you want to be funny or
you want to be cute or you want to talk
about the super moon or whatever you
better be a right and B if you're funny
you better be boring funny right because
you're gonna piss a lot of people off in
today's world that's exact 130 million
people listening at the same time no
matter what joke you make someone's
gonna be bothered well that's it people
are tuning into you they know what
they're gonna get right and they they
like you know they like what you guys do
they're stuck with me doing the game and
they could be in a nursing home they
could be at a frat party but it's still
my voice and if you want to start going
into areas that are off the beaten path
you better be really careful but that's
part of it too I think in especially in
the last few years anyway is that maybe
the NFL more than baseball but baseball
too they're trying to open these sports
up to as many conceivable eyes as
possible so you're not just going out to
the typical football fan the typical
baseball fan they're trying to get
families they're trying to get all these
people down so you better make sure that
you line up with that yeah you're always
trying to get new people under the tent
watching this stuff and you know that's
to me it's also hurt the NFL with these
international games and starting games
at 8:00 a.m. and London and people
aren't seeing them and it's hurt ratings
I think that's one of the issues
everybody's talking why are the NFL
ratings down that's a part of it but
again it's made everybody boring it's
made everybody go right down the middle
lane and every announcer sounds like
everybody else and it's too bad because
the real personalities the Harry Caray's
and guys like that are long gone and and
that that act wouldn't work anymore
yeah Madden and some are all always fun
to listen to it's again you kind of look
forward to them you
like when they were calling your team's
game I don't know why the end I wonder
if the ratings have dropped because
stuff like red zone with is not as much
of a press to watch the game you can
just go click the highlights real quick
yeah maybe it and a lot of that's
fantasy football you don't really care
who wins the game is my tight end in
that game if he's not you know he I got
the tight end for the Jaguars I'm gonna
watch that you know on red zone or
whatever and maybe that's taken away
some while I think it's also added a lot
because the the average fan knows a hell
of a lot more about the sports we're
doing than they ever did and that's a
part of it when you have like when the
world comes down on you the couple times
that it has either for the Randy Moss
thing for The Bachelor we know that we
made a call Randy Moss did like a mock
mooning of the crowd after he scored and
in Green Bay oh yeah and and Joe said it
was disgusting yeah that is disgusting
that is disgust and everybody's like
time to get his [ __ ] head out of his
ass he's always so buttoned up you know
I mean so that that fed the idea that
I'm this like nerd who can harity prude
play-by-play guy which whatever I feel
is disgusting what he did of the fact
that just enough with these guys doing
this new me you know I've done games
where tio Terrell Owens grab the
pom-poms in it you know that stuff's
funny I thought to paying fans in a
playoff game to go to the fans turn your
you know backside to them and fake
shimmying your pants down then go to the
goalpost and kind of do the same thing I
was like come on that's you I think you
need to be better than that Randy and I
are great I saw him last night took a
picture with them and put it on Twitter
you know like we're taking this act on
the road but you know yeah I got a lot
of crap for that it's still your number
one most viewed YouTube thing thank God
I didn't search for nets that's number
one yeah so there it is right there it's
funny
taking our act on the road but so the
other the other thing that they came
down on you for was saying that you're
just as likely to watch The Bachelor as
you are a baseball game yeah and that's
true that's true today but Mike Witt
like I think it was Skip Bayless was
like going nuts on you after that one
wasn't like calling for your job and
stuff and when you have
people who are fellow like broadcasters
do you not like for instance comedians
don't really trash other comedians
because it's like this is a good reason
to you right there's kind of a bit of a
brotherhood so when you're watching skip
bayless you like we skip like I [ __ ] is
your prize I don't care what he said
then or now yeah and and I some of that
stuff is just sensational you know I'm
gonna take a crazy you're gonna I'm
gonna call for this guy's job I mean it
went no what was he joking when he said
it was did he really mean it now he's
like this is Jack bucks son and he says
he's my point was it was Colin Cowherd
asked me and he said you know are you
watching games every night and you know
going to bed watching the West Coast
games and I was like I I have a wife I
have daughters I'm watching The Bachelor
I'm you know cooking dinner I'm you know
I I read and and I'm up on what I need
to be up on but I have a life I'm not a
sports nerd that right and nothing
against it but that's just I'm feel like
there's more to life than just one thing
sports yeah and he got mad at you and
thought you should be fired for what for
what I mean yet there was all these
ended operations every night yeah what
is skipping here yeah yeah exactly it
doesn't matter
here here's the funny part of that I
care less about what he or somebody like
him would think of me than I do the
random guy on Twitter really probably
yeah because you know he's probably no
station Eliza he's you know or awful
announcing does something that's just
clickbait it's just I don't care about
that stuff but it's it's the random guy
that that has a clever thing that it's
like not me look at that guy's cuz that
guy is not confirming something that you
feel deep doubt some [ __ ] saying you
should be fired y'all shut up
but someone going you stinks like well
God they know yeah found out that's how
I started I my first world series I was
27 thinking you know I'm a Yankee
Stadium doing the Yankees and Braves
going out I hope to god I don't get
exposed as a fraud over the next X
number of games and thankfully I didn't
and I've done 18 more since but how was
your first 196 90
have you gotten over that feeling yeah
that's gone I'm yeah I'm not nervous or
yeah I know I can handle whatever's
gonna come my way so you don't have the
thing of like oh well if if the people
in charge read these tweets they're
gonna find out I'm terrible and they're
gonna know that doesn't sink in at all
no that's gonna healthy it should but
yeah and and I think I think there's a
place for all that stuff but that can't
be you know and anybody in a position of
power that's doing hiring at fox is not
being swayed by Twitter right it's there
it's too big of a gamble it's too
you know the the money they have
invested in the NFL let alone in our
booth you know with Troy and me and
financially what they that's not swayed
by Twitter plus you could just have John
Hamm write a letter of recommendation
right and he's got clout correct means
that you're good better yeah better
could do it yeah Paul Rudd could do a
romantic comedy what did you think Tina
Fey did you hear Eddie Vedder's cub song
I didn't hear it no I did not but I
spent the entire here's name-dropping
mmm-hmm tell me I spent the entire
postseason for your buddy's Cubs going
going across the street to Murphy's
bleachers and going up to the rooftop
and just hanging with veteran singing
karaoke with him until 4:30 in the
morning was he good at karaoke no no
it's great and I was doing lead-ins two
songs and he's playing underneath me it
was just it was fun lesson Travis would
you have been bored hanging out there
the beginning I forgot our producer
Travis is the biggest pros Pearl Jam
sweat from runway yeah nobody's the
necklace he has I can tell you honestly
pearl eye I can tell you honestly Eddie
Vetter is the nicest human being to
anybody I've seen it anybody that he
comes in contact with he's like it's
almost not real he's that happy you want
to meet him
no you'd prefer not to right now no you
wouldn't be let down I'm promised that's
amazing guy well everybody pick up the
book it's called lucky bastard there's a
ton of out today it's out today there's
a ton of really great stories in there
it's not just a I mean it's it's I feel
like at a sports boy it's you finally
getting to like
let this out there right yeah like like
say this is who I am you can stop just
creating this thing yeah you know I mean
yeah I said to the publisher I'm sorry
but if this sells one copy or a million
I'm still gonna feel good because at
least it's out there right right so it's
cathartic tomorrow night Joe is at the
92nd Street Y which is an amazing place
to see people we saw so gene Wilder
Auster odd to see Sidney Poitier speak
amazing the best yeah the best yeah yeah
he was an awesome very calm quiet guy to
watch toppers it's nice to be in the
room of them what didn't they video that
didn't I see that with I don't know he
did a thing with Mel Brooks it wasn't
with now Brooks okay then now yeah and
now 92 y dot org if you want some
tickets is a few tickets they probably
released they always do that for the
ticket holders at monthly they can't
make it and also go to some book
signings which are uh you know exciting
yeah the book signings all right how
many people feel my hair plugs sign a
book run your fingers through this how
about you pulling out you give it as a
book more nice I've spent way too much
money on these to give them away
Thursday at the Yogi Berra museum in
Little Falls New Jersey November 23rd a
bixit books a million in Grapevine Texas
with Troy Aikman and on December 5th in
Beverly Hills at the Beverly Hills
Library with Rich Eisen Tata yeah and we
have coming up we got Dennis Quaid next
and I'll be in Fort Lauderdale this
Friday and Saturday at The Improv later
right back and if you're tall and you
meet and you meet Joe look at him in the
eyes because he knows when you're
staring at his hair play though it you
know he can tell it's it's a little bell
that goes off the head thank you so much
all right guys thanks